I'll talk about being here performing
tonight what it what it means to you and
why it's important for you to be here um
being here performing it's an honor
because I think mental health is a very
you know serious issue especially right
now and I think that showing my support
to it it's the least like it is so I'm
here playing two songs talked about
these songs hold on just passed a
million streams that's got to feel
pretty good yeah it feels great I it's
weird because I you know I haven't had a
song and I've actually written on a TV
show of course they're hearing it was
kind of a weird experiences it was
pretty awesome but the the fan base for
that show is so incredible and that the
response has been great and to be able
to just kind of have that kind of a
platform this amazing music the sole
focus right now are we ever going to see
you back on TV or in a movie acting is a
huge passion of mine I mean I've been
working on this music project for the
last two years like full speed but since
I've been like 15 or 16 I've been
writing songs so it's uh I think you
know I don't think you can limit
yourself to just one thing I'm gonna you
know do as much as possible so we're
gonna get a full album like a full
length album I probably have written
like two or three albums like fully so
we're probably gonna pick the best like
twelve fourteen songs from that and put
it on a record can we expect that I
think we're gonna do it one by one right
now and then EP until it's an EP and
then like come with me out and right
after that so that's kind of the process
you Heather Morris is on Dancing with
the Stars this season have you been
watching um I I have I had a really been
I've been in the studio so I'm gonna I'm
gonna check my TiVo and get get on that
there's some good luck text messages I
will have to do that I mean if she's
such a great dancer I don't know I don't
know how fair that is but yeah I'm
definitely in a tuna